dang Samson that is impressive is a
z-fold for really that much better than
the iPhone 13 Pro Max well today we will
find out because we're gonna compare
everything from the design to the
speakers the displays the cameras and
the performance and see how much more
advanced are Samsung's new flagship
foldables compared to Apple's iPhone
let's go ahead and get this thing open
bam right away you see it I like this
new color I tested the Z fold 3 last
year and I liked it but a few usability
things kept me from wanting to use it
even though I was excited to have a
crazy note-taking device that I could
have with me at all times alright there
she is Man the video these stickers are
everywhere is it just me or does this
thing seem smaller and lighter and
probably thinner than the previous one
nope I'm not it is actually lighter than
last year in thinner so they've
definitely improve that and the crazy
thing is compared to the iPhone there's
not much more weight the iPhone actually
feels heavier because it's more compact
compared to this larger size it's
shorter as well because now the screen
is more square but of course if we go
ahead and fold this thing down
wow okay that hinge is strong dang okay
now the old one was not like this it
feels super solid requires a fair amount
of work to kind of close it but when it
does close look at that the Gap is also
a lot smaller than it was before all
right so far I am very impressed as far
as thickness when you do fold it yeah
this thing is thick comparing the front
displays the folds is a lot smaller it's
narrower so holding in the hand is
actually pretty comfortable other than
that thickness and they definitely made
the screen wider it used to have a large
bezel on that left hand side but the
iPhone has a nice large screen now of
course if we go ahead and fold this
thing open and compare it I mean dang
that is where you get a huge screen
difference now of course Apple has face
ID with that Notch here you have a
selection which includes the fingerprint
reader which is built in the power
button and also face recognition now I'm
personally curious how is this going to
work can they use that under display
camera for this all right it looks like
it can it's using that camera it
actually looks surprisingly good on here
I'm excited to check out the quality
because before it was terrible uh but
yeah it does work now of course that's
not going to be super secure it's not
like it has any depth sensors like that
so you probably want to have maybe some
backup security and look at that we have
a full list of warnings do not use your
nail because it could scratch it only
the S Pen it's not dust resistant it is
water resistant but not immersion so you
definitely still have to be careful with
this screen now before we see just how
good this fold screen is I want to take
a listen to the speakers last year was
pretty good but it couldn't beat the
iPhone let's see if it can this year
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that is impressive I think it's better
in every way uh it's louder the bass is
more Punchy and this thing just has two
speakers on the sides it doesn't have
that front facing so I don't know what
you guys heard because we're recording
with the mic on top uh but it is
definitely nicer and what that didn't
show is that if you're holding your hand
facing you you can actually cut the
phone and then your hands kind of take
the audio from the sides and boost it
forward so you get a nice even sound
from left to right because they're the
same speakers instead of the iPhone
which is really good they've improved a
lot but you still have a smaller speaker
on the left that has less bass so
overall I am very impressed getting into
the displays I'm going to start with the
front screen because that is the massive
one but when we open a web page I don't
really see any extra data here uh
everything's larger which is nice but
I'm not getting anything more now right
here we have this article same thing
everything's bigger so if you're blind
it really helps but as far as formatting
you're not getting too much extra real
estate now of course some apps support
side by side which is nice so now I
could be watching a YouTube video
surfing the web maybe looking at
comments at the same time compared to
just having one full screen app on the
iPhone now of course we also have that
front display which is now filled with
fingerprints let me go ahead and turn
that on we can open up that YouTube
video oh look at all that section for
comments you can see a ton of them now
because of how tall of a display this is
but we can switch back over to our
browser
here you go and this actually works well
now not that they made it wider uh
definitely seems more usable now this
display can actually go all the way down
to one Hertz the iPhone can go down to
24 and then up to 120. so this has a
higher range and that will save a ton of
battery life especially for the
always-on display which you can't get on
the iPhone yet now the main display goes
down to 48 Hertz so not as low but it
goes up to 120 and it is super smooth
let's go ahead and max out the
brightness and compare both of these
dang that iPhone gets really bright in
manual mode definitely brighter than the
fold and with that the viewing angles
the same thing now one thing I noticed
is that when I'm looking at it straight
on I don't really notice that crease
from the side you can see it I don't
know if it's more minimal than it was
before it doesn't look too bad but this
whole time uh just you know stood out to
me that I didn't notice it and then also
switch switching apps we have this nice
little quick shortcut menu on the bottom
so I've just been literally just hitting
it and then bam all of a sudden it pops
up and I don't have to go to my home
page or do my app launcher now playing
back this HDR video the Samsung fold 4
is actually brighter so that means that
they're controlling the max brightness
when you're you just regularly using it
like on that web page and man I mean the
colors pop you have a little bit more
contrast the brightness pops more so we
adjust that top camera for the brights
it looks better in pretty much every way
now of course you have these large black
bars here compared to here but the video
is still larger and then we can go and
zoom it in so now we're cutting off more
of the video than here but you're
getting a massive massive uh basically
screen to look at for video and on the
iPhone of course we have just that
little Notch that is cutting out a
portion of it so it looks like sometimes
the fold actually shows see more of the
vertical like that bar whereas the
iPhone it's wider cuts it out and then
of course here the sides are cropped out
like some of these other edges here
overall I am very impressed with the
folds display as well the iPhone had a
big Improvement to HDR but now this is
even better now of course another big
selling point is the S Pen and that's
something that you can't do with your
iPhone they have this updated case for
it that is a little bulkier than I
thought but offers a lot of protection
and it has this kickstand here so you
can put your phone down and they'll
actually hold it or you can just pull
this whole thing out and pop in the S
Pen section and then it will just stay
right there on the back of your phone
now of course that does increase the
thickness if you have this in your
pocket I mean that's gonna stick out
even more so I don't know I think I
probably avoid it this part has a little
bit of tape which I did not take off but
I think realistically for people that
care about the S Pen it would have been
so nice to be able to have it built in
even if that meant having a Mini S Pen I
think that would be a groundbreaking
feature an addition that would make a
lot of people want to upgrade or upgrade
from other devices that supported it in
the past and now let's compare the
performance obviously we have the a15
bionic with six gigs of RAM compared to
the Snapdragon 8 plus gen one I don't
know why they called it that and here I
believe we have 12 gigs of RAM let's go
ahead and run the CPU test here we go
and that multi-core score isn't actually
as big of a difference as I expected 4
000 compared to 4700 single core score
obviously that's a bigger difference 29
so Qualcomm can't catch up with Apple at
this point but with this latest jump
with the plus added it is Graphics that
were mainly improved we're going to run
gfx bench and I'm going to use both a
1440p Aztec Ruins as well as the new 4k
one just so we could see what kind of a
difference we get and look at that guys
I cannot believe my eyes uh for this
cross-platform test the fold 4 with that
new Snapdragon actually beat it for the
4K test we have 20.8 frames per second
compared to 21. and then the easier
1440p test we have 36.7 compared to 43
frames per second that was running with
opengl it started running Vulcan looks
like it's one FPS lower and I canceled
running out through that but that is
impressive
um I don't know how that's possible but
the other thing that I do know is with
this huge screen I really want to see
what it's like to play
um okay this is crazy but Ian played
last year and it was really nice and
just having such a big screen to play if
you are a fan of mobile games and that
graphics performance that we now saw I
mean this is definitely gonna be a great
gaming phone now as far as cameras both
phones have three on the back Samsung
upgraded the full to a 50 megapixel now
for a main shooter and then on the front
we have a 10 megapixel compared to uh
12. now of course we also have the under
display camera let's go ahead and test
it out dang that looks better than I
expected at first it shows up very
blurry and messy and then the AI
algorithm kicks in and makes it look way
better than before here's a side by side
you guys let me know is this acceptable
enough image to accept an under display
compared to the iPhone now you guys know
how we like to do camera comparisons not
in these videos here where we have one
or two photos we want to do it blind
style which is super fun you guys can
vote along with us so we are going to be
doing that and that's coming up soon
make sure you guys are subscribed to see
the iPhone versus The Fold 4 and the s22
ultra which is going to make it even
more interesting now with all of that
said I am just very impressed with this
fold when you look online it just seems
like it's just a tiny update no changes
why did they even make another one but
in reality when you get in your hand you
see all the small updates they do add up
to a great device and I'm excited to be
using it this following week or maybe
even longer now I think my one complaint
is that the S Pen is not built in if
they did that it would make it such a
big upgrade instead of having a case and
having that pen that's you know makes it
thicker and then the other one is just
pricing of course this iPhone is 1100
bucks this one here is still almost two
grand now sure they'll give you some
extra storage uh things like that but
people are expecting the prices on these
fold phones to go down as the
generations came out but they haven't
they're still extremely expensive so you
guys let me know would you be willing to
spend that much money for a fold and
what you think about this one click that
Circle above to subscribe so you guys
don't miss out on that camera comparison
check out one of those great videos
right over there this has been Max and
I'll see you in the next video
[Music]